This is 99% invisible. I am Roman Mars. At the end of the calendar year and into the new year, the 99PI staff collects a bunch of short, joyful little stories that are fun to produce and make us happy. We call them mini stories. This is the third and final episode of this batch and the 14th volume overall, and it's a good one. We have stories about surprisingly architectural sports commentary, Ben Franklin's role in daylight saving time, and the origin of the fireball. Wake the kids, stay with us. So I'm with producer Emma Fitzgerald, Emmett, if past his president, you either have
This is 99% invisible. I am Roman Mars. At the end of the calendar year and into the new year, the 99PI staff collects a bunch of short, joyful little stories that are fun to produce and make us happy. We call them mini stories. This is the third and final episode of this batch and the 14th volume overall, and it's a good one. We have stories about surprisingly architectural sports commentary, Ben Franklin's role in daylight saving time, and the origin of the fireball. Wake the kids, stay with us. So I'm with producer Emma Fitzgerald, Emmett, if past his president, you either have|||这是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在历年末和新年初之际，99PI的工作人员收集了一堆短小、欢乐的小故事，制作起来很有趣，也让我们感到快乐。我们称之为迷你故事。这是这批节目的第三集也是最后一集，总计第14卷，非常精彩。我们有关于出人意料的建筑学风格体育解说、本杰明·富兰克林在夏令时中的角色，以及消防滑竿起源的故事。叫醒孩子们，收听我们的节目。我现在和制片人埃玛·菲茨杰拉德在一起，埃玛，如果过去的总统可以作为参照，你手头要么
a sports story for us or an environmental story for us. Yeah. So which is it? This week it's sports Roman. Fantastic. Okay. I am ready. All right.
a sports story for us or an environmental story for us. Yeah. So which is it? This week it's sports Roman. Fantastic. Okay. I am ready. All right.|||有一个体育故事，要么有一个环保故事。是的。那到底是哪个？这周是体育，罗曼。太棒了。好的。我准备好了。好吧。
So as I imagine you might have noticed, I got pretty into biking during the pandemic. I did notice you would put a little note on Slack that would say, like, I'm going to be gone for the next hour. And it would be like, and it was because you were biking. Yeah, I mean, I had ridden bikes before COVID hit, but I kind of levelled up during the pandemic. I took that canceled gym membership money in Butter Road bike and some of the proper outfits and started riding up and
So as I imagine you might have noticed, I got pretty into biking during the pandemic. I did notice you would put a little note on Slack that would say, like, I'm going to be gone for the next hour. And it would be like, and it was because you were biking. Yeah, I mean, had ridden bikes before COVID hit, but I kind of levelled up during the pandemic. I took that canceled gym membership money in Butter Road bike and some of the proper outfits and started riding up and|||如你所见，我疫情期间迷上了骑行。我确实注意到你会在Slack上发个小便签，上面写着，比如我接下来一个小时不在。然后就会显示，那是因为你去骑车了。是的，我是说，在新冠疫情爆发之前我就骑过车，但我在疫情期间可以说是升级了。我拿了退掉的健身房会员卡的钱去买了一辆公路自行车和一些合适的装备，开始骑着它上上下下
down the East Bay Hills, torturing myself. And then a few months in, you know, to this new hobby, the Tour de France happened. And I had never really watched the Tour de France before, but I figured, you know, I'm into this now, give this a try. And what was immediately clear was that it's just like a very different spectacle from the other kinds of sports that I was used to watching, you know, things like basketball or soccer. Yeah. And then the biggest difference is really just one of time.
down the East Bay Hills, torturing myself. And then a few months in, you know, to this new hobby, the Tour de France happened. And I had never really watched the Tour de France before, but I figured, you know, I'm into this now, give this a try. And what was immediately clear was that it's just like a very different spectacle from the other kinds of sports that I was used to watching, you know, things like basketball or soccer. Yeah. And then the biggest difference is really just one of time.|||东湾的山丘，折磨着自己。然后几个月后，你知道的，在这个新爱好期间，环法自行车赛开始了。我以前从未真正看过去环法，但我想，既然我现在迷上了这个，那就尝试一下吧。显而易见的是，它与我习惯观看的其他类型的体育运动（比如篮球或足球）有着截然不同的观赏体验。是的。最大的不同其实就是时间。
Like the tour stretches on for several weeks, and there's a stage nearly every day that lasts like four to six hours. And within each stage, you know, there are moments of really intense, exciting action, but there's also long stretches where there isn't a whole lot happening. At least, at least to my eyes, as like an unsophisticated newbie. And so, you know, I wasn't giving it my undivided attention all the time. It kind of became this sort of pleasant morning ritual that I would have on in the background as I, you know, drank my coffee and wrote my morning emails. Yeah. It sounds kind of like slow TV, like watching a train over the course of 12 hours. That's why yeah, yeah, exactly. That was at least, at least I was having, I was pretty and maybe that's disrespectful
Like the tour stretches on for several weeks, and there's a stage nearly every day that lasts like four to six hours. And within each stage, you know, there's moments of really intense, exciting action, but there's also long stretches where there isn't a whole lot happening. At least, at least to my eyes, as like an unsophisticated newbie. And so, you know, I wasn't giving it my undivided attention all the time. It kind of became this sort of pleasant morning ritual that I would have on in the background as I, you know, drank my coffee and wrote my morning emails. Yeah. It sounds kind of like slow TV, like watching a train over the course of 12 hours. That's why yeah, yeah, exactly. That was at least, at least I was having, I was pretty and maybe that's disrespectful|||比如比赛持续好几周，几乎每天都有一个赛段，持续四到六个小时。在每个赛段中，你知道的，有一些非常紧张、令人兴奋的动作，但也有很长的路段并没有发生太多事情。至少，至少在我这个毫无经验的新手眼中是这样的。所以，你知道的，我并没有把全部注意力都放在上面。它有点变成了一种令人愉快的早晨仪式，当我喝着咖啡、写早间邮件时，它就在背景里播放。听起来有点像慢电视，就像花12小时看一辆火车。这就是为什么，是的，是的，完全正确。至少我是这么觉得的，也许这有点不尊重
and serious cycling fans, but, um, but, you know, as I was doing this, I started to notice something kind of strange, which was that the cycling announcers they don't just talk about cycling. And one of the things that they really talk about a lot is architecture. Looking down here at the Church of Saint-Jean, built in 1862 in the shape of a Greek cross. On the debris of the old parish church of Saint- San and the old it's got a porch a tight belt Hour the roof flanked with four pinnacles a mountain by a spire burning a huge cockle. Can't see it from this angle Oh, yes again. No, it is right on the front
and serious cycling fans, but, um, but, you, as I was doing this, I started to notice something kind of strange, which was that the cycling announcers they don't just talk about cycling. And one of the things that they really talk about a lot is architecture. Looking down here at the Church of Saint-Jean, built in 1862 in the shape of a Greek cross. On the debris of the old parish church of Saint- San and the old it's got a porch a tight belt Hour the roof flanked with four pinnacles a mountain by a spire burning a huge cockle. Can't see it from this angle Oh, yes again. No, it is right on the front|||那些严肃的骑行粉丝，但是，嗯，但是，在这样做的时候，我开始注意到一件奇怪的事情，那就是自行车解说员不仅仅谈论自行车。他们经常谈论的事情之一就是建筑。向下看这里的圣让教堂，建于1862年，呈希腊十字架形状。在圣萨恩老教区教堂的废墟上，旧的它有一个门廊，一个紧凑的钟楼，屋顶两侧有四个尖塔，一座山被一个尖顶燃烧着一个巨大的扇贝。从这个角度看不到。哦，是的，又来了。不，它就在正面。
Well spotted Cockadoo the Lou Whoa, I could get into this. Yeah I'm called the Doodaloo. Whoa, I could get into this. Yeah. Yeah, it's like, it's like this extremely detailed architectural description of, you know, church or something. And if you watch a lot of this, you notice this all the time.
Well spotted Cockadoo the Lou Whoa, I could get into this. Yeah I'm called the Doodaloo. Whoa, I could get into this. Yeah. Yeah, it's like, it's like this extremely detailed architectural description of, you know, church or something. And if you watch a lot of this, you notice this all the time.|||观察敏锐。哇，我能迷上这个。是的，我被称为“Doodaloo”。哇，我能迷上这个。是的。是的，这就像，这就像是对教堂什么的极其详细的建筑描述。如果你看很多这样的比赛，你会一直注意到这一点。
Like, the announcers will be talking about, you know, team, Yombo Vismas tactics and whether Primoz Roblich has what it takes to recover from that crash he suffered earlier in the stage and then suddenly they're talking about like an Abbey. This is an Abbey by the books of it, the old Abbey del Oktu. And it was at this Abbey in 1940 that the Mona Lisa was moved to, along with more than a thousand other paintings from the Louvre to be put in storage for safety at the outbreak of the war. So quite a significant role in protecting some of the great artwork of not just the France, but of the world.
Like, the announcers will be talking about, you know, team, Yombo Vismas tactics and whether Primoz Roblich has what it takes to recover from that crash he suffered earlier in the stage and then suddenly they're talking about like an Abbey. This is an Abbey by the books of it, the old Abbey del Oktu. And it was at this Abbey in 1940 that the Mona Lisa was moved to, along with more than a thousand other paintings from the Louvre to be put in storage for safety at the outbreak of the war. So quite a significant role in protecting some of the great artwork of not just the France, but of the world.|||比如，解说员会谈论珍宝-维斯玛车队的战术，以及普里莫日·罗格里奇是否有能力从他在比赛早些时候遭遇的撞车事故中恢复过来，然后突然间他们就在谈论一座修道院。从书本上看，这是一座修道院，老奥克图修道院。1940年，《蒙娜丽莎》连同卢浮宫的另外一千多幅画作被转移到这座修道院，在战争爆发时存放起来以确保安全。因此，它在保护不仅是法国，而且是世界的伟大艺术品方面发挥了非常重要的作用。
Well, I'm really into this. This is like, I had no idea that the announcements had so much history and context. That is really so. Yeah, yeah, I love it too. And you know, it's just, I just find it so charming because it's like, you know, these serious sports announcers have like a sort of nearly encyclopedic knowledge of random buildings and little towns like throughout the French countryside.
Well, I'm really into this. This is like, I had no idea that the announcements had so much history and context. That is really so. Yeah, yeah, I love it too. And you know, it's just, I just find it so charming because it's like, you know, these serious sports announcers have like a sort of nearly encyclopedic knowledge of random buildings and little towns like throughout the French countryside.|||我很喜欢这个。这就像，我不知道解说中竟然有这么多的历史和背景。确实如此。是的，是的，我也很喜欢。你知道的，我只是觉得它太迷人了，因为这些严肃的体育解说员对法国乡村各处的各种建筑和小镇拥有几乎百科全书般的知识。
This is the valley where in 218 BC, Hannibal came through here with 90,000 men and 10,000 horsemen and 37 elephants on his way back home. And imagine what the row conditions were like in those days, Paul. It was pretty tough for the elephants, I have to say once they got over the top because fortunately with their large pads they didn't slip too much on the snow. Would there be Indian elephants? No, actually there were African elephants. Very unusual, I'm surprised they could train them. Four minutes and 18 seconds, 92 kilometers to go now.
This is the valley where in 218 BC, Hannibal came through here with 90,000 men and 10,000 horsemen and 37 elephants on his way back home. And imagine what the row conditions were like in those days, Paul. It was pretty tough for the elephants, I have to say once they got over the top because fortunately with their large pads they didn't slip too much on the snow. Would there be Indian elephants? No, actually there were African elephants. Very unusual, I'm surprised they could train them. Four minutes and 18 seconds, 92 kilometers to go now.|||这里是公元前218年汉尼拔率领9万步兵、1万骑兵和37头大象在回家的路上经过的山谷。想象一下那时的道路状况是什么样的，保罗。我必须说，大象一旦翻过山顶就挺艰难的，好在它们有厚厚的大垫子，在雪地上不会滑倒太多。会是印度象吗？不，实际上是非洲象。非常罕见，我很惊讶他们能训练它们。还剩4分18秒，92公里。
Here is our poor man, left on the way. I don't even know how to react to that. That's just like, that's just stunning digression. This is totally new to me. Is this the way it's always been? Have they always been this Wikipedia of architecture and world history at their fingertips and presented it when they're announcing the race? Yeah, I wanted to answer that question.
Here is our poor man, left on the way. I don't even know how to react to that. That's just like, that's just stunning digression. This is totally new to me. Is this the way it's always been? Have they always been this Wikipedia of architecture and world history at their fingertips and presented it when they're announcing the race? Yeah, I wanted to answer that question.|||这是我们可怜的人，被落在路上了。我都不知道该如何反应。这简直是惊人的题外话。这对我来说完全是新鲜事。一直以来都是这样吗？他们在解说比赛时，难道一直都是把建筑和世界历史的百科全书烂熟于心并展现出来吗？是的，我想回答这个问题。
And there's really one person who I think is best equipped to explain how we got here. And he's actually one of the announcers who you just heard there talking about African elephants. His name is Phil Liggett. And, you know, he's kind of like the most famous voice in professional cycling. In fact, there's a documentary about him that came out last year called Phil Liggett, the voice of cycling. And I talked to Phil on Zoom and he basically told me that he's been doing the Tour de France for decades. And in the very beginning, he was really one of the only English-speaking cycling commentators in the world. I work for the BBC, for ITV, for CBS, to channel 70 in Australia, CBCC in Canada, Television, New Zealand, Star Television in China.
And there's really one person who I think is best equipped to explain how we got here. And he's actually one of the announcers who you just heard there talking about African elephants. His name is Phil Liggett. And, you know, he's kind of like the most famous voice in professional cycling. In fact, there's a documentary about him that came out last year called Phil Liggett, the voice of cycling. And I talked to Phil on Zoom and he basically told me that he's been doing the Tour de France for decades. And in the very beginning, he was really one of the only English-speaking cycling commentators in the world. I work for the BBC, for ITV, for CBS, to channel 70 in Australia, CBCC in Canada, Television, New Zealand, Star Television in China.|||真正有一个人我认为最适合解释我们是如何走到这一步的。他其实就是你刚才听到谈论非洲象的解说员之一。他的名字叫菲尔·利杰特。你知道的，他可以说是职业自行车赛中最著名的声音。事实上，去年有一部关于他的纪录片上映，名叫《菲尔·利杰特：自行车赛之声》。我和菲尔在Zoom上聊了聊，他基本上告诉我他解说环法自行车赛已经几十年了。在最开始的时候，他真的是世界上仅有的几个说英语的自行车评论员之一。我为BBC、ITV、CBS工作，为澳大利亚70频道、加拿大CBCC、新西兰电视台、中国星空卫视工作。
I work for everyone. Phil said, you know, it's a little hard to pinpoint exactly when the whole Chateau Church Abbey commentary got started. But he, he does remember one moment in particular. He was working with his long-term partner. They were a famous duo, the late great Paul Sherwin. And the cameras panned over this dilapidated old Abby. A real wreck, it was a ruin. And I just jokingly said to Paul Sherwin, so hey, Paul, this old Abby here,
I work for everyone. Phil said, you know, it's a little hard to pinpoint exactly when the whole Chateau Church Abbey commentary got started. But he, he does remember one moment in particular. He was working with his long-term partner. They were a famous duo, the late great Paul Sherwin. And the cameras panned over this dilapidated old Abby. A real wreck, it was a ruin. And I just jokingly said to Paul Sherwin, so hey, Paul, this old Abby here,|||我为所有人工作。菲尔说，你知道，很难确切指出城堡、教堂、修道院的解说是从什么时候开始的。但他确实特别记住了某个时刻。他当时和他的长期搭档一起工作。他们是一个著名的二人组，已故伟大的保罗·舍温。摄像机扫过这座破旧的老修道院。简直是一片废墟。我只是半开玩笑地对保罗·舍温说：嘿，保罗，这座老修道院，
it needs a bit of innovation, isn't it? As a joke, I thought, Ruvia was probably 14th century. And Paul looked at, he said, oh yeah, he said, they're really the 14th century. And Paul looked at, he said, oh yeah, he said, there are literally 14 lives there. And Phil looked at Paul, just like, how did you know that? Like, how did you know that we have 14 to live there? Like you're a cycling journalist.
it needs a bit of innovation, isn't it? As a joke, I thought, Ruvia was probably 14th century. And Paul looked at, he said, oh yeah, he said, they're really the 14th century. And Paul looked at Phil, just like, how did you know that? Like, how did you know that we have 14 to live there? Like you're a cycling journalist.|||它需要一点创新，不是吗？我开玩笑地想，鲁维亚可能建于14世纪。保罗看了一眼，说道：哦，是的，他说，它们真的是14世纪的。保罗看着菲尔，就像在说：你怎么知道的？就像，你怎么知道那里有14个人的？你明明是个自行车记者。
And so how did he know it? Well, Paul had lived in France before when he was a pro cyclist. And I think that in that specific instance, it was just kind of like a fun fact that he had learned along the way. But they started to do more of that, just like offering these like little bits of commentary about the landscape that the bikers were passing through
And so how did he know it? Well, Paul had lived in France before when he was a pro cyclist. And I think that in that specific instance, it was just kind of like a fun fact that he had learned along the way. But they started to do more of that, just like offering these like little bits of commentary about the landscape that the bikers were passing through|||那他是怎么知道的呢？保罗以前做过职业自行车手，在法国住过。我想在那个特定的情况下，这只是他在经历中学到的一个有趣的事实。但他们开始做更多这样的事情，就像提供这些关于骑行者穿过的风景的小解说一样，
the buildings and the flora and the fauna. And I think part of it at the time was that they were really trying to sell cycling to an American audience who was not as familiar with the sport as people in Europe. But really, people from all over the world started writing in to say that they loved it. And pretty soon, the Tour de France itself sort of realized what was happening. The Tour de France brought up when they heard what we're doing, and they started to sell a country more.
the buildings and the flora and the fauna. And I think part of it at the time was that they were really trying to sell cycling to an American audience who was not as familiar with the sport as people in Europe. But really, people from all over the world started writing in to say that they loved it. And pretty soon, the Tour de France itself sort of realized what was happening. The Tour de France brought up when they heard what we're doing, and they started to sell a country more.|||建筑、植物和动物。我想当时的一部分原因确实是他们试图向对这项运动不如欧洲人那么熟悉的美国观众推广自行车运动。但实际上，来自世界各地的人们开始写信说他们非常喜欢。很快，环法自行车赛本身也意识到了发生了什么。当环法自行车赛听到我们在做什么时，他们提了出来，并开始更多地宣传这个国家。
The Tour basically realized that they could use this to their advantage. What Phil and Paul were doing. It filled told me that this was all happening at a time when the race wasn't doing very well financially. And people in France were actually getting kind of annoyed because it would lead to all of these road closures. There was a sense that it was like bad for business. And so when the tour organizers picked up on what Phil and Paul were doing, they were
The Tour basically realized that they could use this to their advantage. What Phil and Paul were doing. It filled told me that this was all happening at a time when the race wasn't doing very well financially. And people in France were actually getting kind of annoyed because it would lead to all of these road closures. There was a sense that it was like bad for business. And so when the tour organizers picked up on what Phil and Paul were doing, they were|||环法车队基本上意识到他们可以利用这一点来为自己谋利。菲尔和保罗在做的事。菲尔告诉我，这一切发生的时候，比赛的财务状况并不是很好。法国人实际上开始感到有些恼火，因为这会导致所有这些道路封闭。人们觉得这对生意不好。因此，当赛事组织者注意到菲尔和保罗在做什么时，他们
like, oh, we could make this work for us and almost reframe the tour as like a three-week long advertisement for the country of France. So it's competitive cycling like wrapped in this advertisement for the French Tourism Board. Yeah, exactly. And so they started telling the camera operators to try and get pretty shots of the beautiful old churches and the bridges and waterfalls, and they encouraged Phil and Paul to talk about that stuff.
like, oh, we could make this work for us and almost reframe the tour as like a three-week long advertisement for the country of France. So it's competitive cycling like wrapped in this advertisement for the French Tourism Board. Yeah, exactly. And so they started telling the camera operators to try and get pretty shots of the beautiful old churches and the bridges and waterfalls, and they encouraged Phil and Paul to talk about that stuff.|||觉得，哦，我们可以利用这一点，几乎把环法自行车赛重新包装成法国长达三周的广告。所以这就是包裹在法国旅游局广告中的竞技自行车赛。是的，完全正确。因此，他们开始告诉摄像师尽量拍下美丽的古老教堂、桥梁和瀑布的漂亮镜头，并鼓励菲尔和保罗谈论这些东西。
And for a while, they had to do all the research themselves, but eventually the tour actually started producing this incredible book for them. Which they call the speaker's guide to the Tour de France. Tourists are an historical information. And in the book, because every stage and every monument or old house or garden or bird, in that region that we passed through is picked it in here. So it's basically a guide book to the French countryside, except it's designed exclusively for Phil and like a handful of other people who are cycling commentators for the tour. Like exclusively for them, like meaning that they printed it just for them.
And for a while, they had to do all the research themselves, but eventually the tour actually started producing this incredible book for them. Which they call the speaker's guide to the Tour de France. Tourists are an historical information. And in the book, because every stage and every monument or old house or garden or bird, in that region that we passed through is picked it in here. So it's basically a guide book to the French countryside, except it's designed exclusively for Phil and like a handful of other people who are cycling commentators for the tour. Like exclusively for them, like meaning that they printed it just for them.|||有一段时间，他们必须自己做所有研究，但最终环法赛真的开始为他们制作这本不可思议的书。他们称之为《环法自行车赛解说员指南》。游客是历史信息。在这本书里，因为我们经过的那个地区的每一个赛段、每一个古迹、老房子、花园或鸟类都在这里有描述。所以它基本上是一本法国乡村指南，除了它是专门为菲尔和少数几个环法自行车解说员设计的。就像专门为他们定制的，意思是这是专门为他们印刷的。
Like it's not available to the general public at all. No, no, no, no, like you can't even, it's like pretty hard to find a copy, even if you're like searching on like eBay and stuff. Like they don't even, even if you're like a cycling journalist, you can't get a copy. It's just like people, it's like for the handful of people who are on the mic doing the commentating for the, the various TV stations that are broadcasting the event. Phil show me his just like through the zoom and you know, it's basically just like this giant homemade book with like hundreds of hundreds of pages. And he said that it's really all put together by this one person.
Like it's not available to the general public at all. No, no, no, no, like you can't even, it's like pretty hard to find a copy, even if you're like searching on like eBay and stuff. Like they don't even, even if you're like a cycling journalist, you can't get a copy. It's just like people, it's like for the handful of people who are on the mic doing the commentating for the, the various TV stations that are broadcasting the event. Phil show me his just like through the zoom and you know, it's basically just like this giant homemade book with like hundreds of hundreds of pages. And he said that it's really all put together by this one person.|||普通大众根本买不到。不，不，不，不，就像你甚至无法买到，在eBay之类的网站上搜索都很难找到一本。甚至如果你是一个自行车记者，你也拿不到一本。它就像是给少数在话筒前为转播赛事的各大电视台进行解说的人准备的。菲尔通过Zoom向我展示了他的那本，你知道的，它基本上就像一本有成百上千页的巨大自制书。他说这实际上是由一个人全部整理出来的。
And every year and the two routes is announced the following year in October. It's her job to drive every inch of the route, all two and a half to three and a half thousand miles of it. And basically, document all of the points of interest that the cameras might linger on during the race. Every shadow, every palace, every garden, the mountains, the floor, and the floor, and the building, and this truck. And then on the day before the tour starts, the organization gives every commentator a copy of the book in English and French. And each entry just has like a bunch of interesting tidbits and facts about particular buildings or bridges that, you know, the cameras might pass over.
And every year and the two routes is announced the following year in October. It's her job to drive every inch of the route, all two and a half to three and a half thousand miles of it. And basically, document all of the points of interest that the cameras might linger on during the race. Every shadow, every palace, every garden, the mountains, the floor, and the floor, and the building, and this truck. And then on the day before the tour starts, the organization gives every commentator a copy of the book in English and French. And each entry just has like a bunch of interesting tidbits and facts about particular buildings or bridges that, you know, the cameras might pass over.|||每年，两条路线都会在第二年的10月公布。她的工作就是开车走遍路线的每一寸，所有两千五百到三千五百英里的路程。基本上，记录下比赛期间摄像机可能会停留的所有兴趣点。每一个阴影、每一座宫殿、每一个花园、山脉、地板、楼层、建筑以及这辆卡车。然后在比赛开始前一天，组织会给每位解说员一本英文和法文版的书。每个条目都包含一堆关于特定建筑或桥梁的有趣花絮和事实，你知道的，摄像机可能会掠过这些地方。
But there's this moment in the in the broadcast that Phil described him where it's like you have to make sure that you have found the right thing like what you're looking at on the cameras is the thing that you're you don't want to read the facts for the wrong shadow. So, and so he described all these moments to me where he would just be looking over and seeing his partner Paul, like frantically trying to find the right building in the book. And I'm watching Paul savagely rip the book apart to find that picture of this dumb shadow
But there's this moment in the in the broadcast that Phil described him where it's like you have to make sure that you have found the right thing like what you're looking at on the cameras is the thing that you're you don't want to read the facts for the wrong shadow. So, and so he described all these moments to me where he would just be looking over and seeing his partner Paul, like frantically trying to find the right building in the book. And I'm watching Paul savagely rip the book apart to find that picture of this dumb shadow|||但在菲尔描述的广播中，有这样一个时刻，就像你必须确保你找到了正确的东西，比如你在摄像机上看到的就是你要找的东西，你可不想为一个错误的阴影去朗读事实。所以，他向我描述了所有这些时刻，他会转过头去看到他的搭档保罗，在书里拼命地寻找正确的建筑。我看着保罗疯狂地把书撕开，为了找到那个蠢阴影的照片
and I'm just dying to laugh. I'm so low on a good black car because I'm live on that laugh. I'm so low on the black car because I'm live on that. And I can see the sweat on his brow because he's desperate. Then all of a sudden he'll come in. I'll say, what do you think of that, Paul? And then Paul, you know, who in the meantime had, you know, been, been, had found the right page, which is cool. He read off a few interesting facts about the building, as if you knew them, you know, right off the top of his head. What do we know about that, Paul?
and I'm just dying to laugh. I'm so low on a good black car because I'm live on that laugh. I'm so low on the black car because I'm live on that. And I can see the sweat on his brow because he's desperate. Then all of a sudden he'll come in. I'll say, what do you think of that, Paul? And then Paul, you know, who in the meantime had, you know, been, been, had found the right page, which is cool. He read off a few interesting facts about the building, as if you knew them, you know, right off the top of his head. What do we know about that, Paul?|||我简直快笑死了。我正在直播，所以我很难保持镇定。我因为正在直播而很难保持镇定。我能看到他额头上的汗水，因为他绝望了。然后突然他就会接话。我会说：保罗，你觉得那个怎么样？然后保罗，你知道的，在此期间他一直在找，已经找到了正确的那页，太棒了。他念出了关于这座建筑的一些有趣事实，就好像他早就知道一样，你知道的，脱口而出。关于那个我们知道些什么，保罗？
The Pontagoe. This is one of those med-even villages I was talking about a little earlier. They were all very much fortified. They've got a lot of very narrow streets in there. It's situated right on the Overseas Valley, and it was extremely important to young years gone by for its military and military control. Just looking at the problem there at the back with a flat tie. As you're waiting for the first time.
The Pontagoe. This is one of those med-even villages I was talking about a little earlier. They were all very much fortified. They've got a lot of very narrow streets in there. It's situated right on the Overseas Valley, and it was extremely important to young years gone by for its military and military control. Just looking at the problem there at the back with a flat tie. As you're waiting for the first time.|||蓬塔戈。这就是我刚才提到中世纪村庄之一。它们都防御森严。里面有很多非常狭窄的街道。它坐落在海外山谷上，在过去的年轻岁月中，对于军事和军事控制极其重要。看看后面那个爆胎的问题。当你第一次等待时。
You'd never know. He's been tearing through this book, trying to come up with that fact about the military might of the Uwez Valley or whatever. No, I mean, they're amazing broadcasters. That's what you really take away from these clips is just how good they are at their job. Yeah, they're really talented. And Philly, he says he gets emails all the time from people who appreciate this detail and want to know,
You'd never know. He's been tearing through this book, trying to come up with that fact about the military might of the Uwez Valley or whatever. No, I mean, they're amazing broadcasters. That's what you really take away from these clips is just how good they are at their job. Yeah, they're really talented. And Philly, he says he gets emails all the time from people who appreciate this detail and want to know,|||你绝对猜不到。他一直在翻阅这本书，试图找出关于乌韦兹山谷军事力量之类的事实。不，我的意思是，他们是出色的广播员。从这些片段中你真正能体会到的是他们工作做得有多好。是的，他们真的很有才华。菲利说他经常收到那些欣赏这种细节并想知道的人发来的电子邮件，
like the exact route from the tour from that past year because they saw this particular village that they thought was beautiful. And I think in France too, it also has worked. The tour is thought to be a real showcase for the country now. And towns will actually pay money to have the tour go through their town because it will bring in the tourist revenue and also that people from all around
like the exact route from the tour from that past year because they saw this particular village that they thought was beautiful. And I think in France too, it also has worked. The tour is thought to be a real showcase for the country now. And towns will actually pay money to have the tour go through their town because it will bring in the tourist revenue and also that people from all around|||比如那一年环法赛的具体路线，因为他们看到了这个他们认为很美的特定村庄。我想在法国也是如此，这也起到了作用。现在人们认为环法赛是该国真正的展示窗口。城镇甚至会付钱让环法赛穿过他们的城镇，因为这会带来旅游收入，而且来自世界各地的人们
the world will kind of get a chance to see their town and maybe hear someone like Phil describe, you know, their chat to- You're a 14th century Abby. Yeah, exactly. And they might want to come visit sometime. Well, that's amazing. I am really, really impressed by Phil as a broadcaster
the world will kind of get a chance to see their town and maybe hear someone like Phil describe, you know, their chat to- You're a 14th century Abby. Yeah, exactly. And they might want to come visit sometime. Well, that's amazing. I am really, really impressed by Phil as a broadcaster|||也有机会看到他们的城镇，也许还能听到像菲尔这样的人描述，你知道的，他们的闲聊——一座14世纪的修道院。是的，完全正确。他们可能想找个时间来看看。这太棒了。我对菲尔作为一名广播员的印象非常深刻，
and it's so much fun to listen to him. So this is so great. I'm now into it. I'm now gonna watch the Tour de France. I'm like, I love this idea. Yeah, put it on in the background, at the very least. That sounds great. Emmett, thank you so much for introducing me to feel like it.
and it's so much fun to listen to him. So this is so great. I'm now into it. I'm now gonna watch the Tour de France. I'm like, I love this idea. Yeah, put it on in the background, at the very least. That sounds great. Emmett, thank you so much for introducing me to feel like it.|||听他说话太有趣了。这真是太棒了。我现在迷上它了。我接下来要看环法自行车赛了。我觉得，我喜欢这个主意。是的，至少把它当作背景音乐播放吧。听起来不错。埃玛，非常感谢你向我介绍菲尔·利杰特。
I think that's a gem of a human. Thank you, Roman. Okay, so I'm here with Chris Baroubaik. Chris, what do you have for us? Hi, Romans. So over the summer, you might remember we did a story about daylight saving time. Yes, saving no S saving with no S. Yes, the biggest news you can use. I have ever provided on this podcast is that it is daylight saving time. So I have a follow up to that story. And before I get there, just a quick recap of what we talked about with daylight saving time, it was episode 443.
I think that's a gem of a human. Thank you, Roman. Okay, so I'm here with Chris Baroubaik. Chris, what do you have for us? Hi, Romans. So over the summer, you might remember we did a story about daylight saving time. Yes, saving no S saving with no S. Yes, the biggest news you can use. I have ever provided on this podcast is that it is daylight saving time. So I have a follow up to that story. And before I get there, just a quick recap of what we talked about with daylight saving time, it was episode 443.|||我认为他是一个宝藏般的人。谢谢你，罗曼。好的，我现在和克里斯·巴鲁拜克在一起。克里斯，你给我们带来了什么？嗨，罗曼。所以在夏天，你可能还记得我们做过一个关于夏令时（daylight saving time）的故事。是的，saving没有S，saving没有S。是的，我在这个播客中提供过的最实用的重大新闻就是这是夏令时。所以我对那个故事有一个后续。在此之前，先简单回顾一下我们讨论过的夏令时，那是第443集。
We told the story of William Willett. He's kind of the father of daylight saving time. He was this British architect who campaigned for the idea for years. And then he died in one year after his death, the British parliament finally tried out daylight saving time. And that's why we have it today.
We told the story of William Willett. He's kind of the father of daylight saving time. He was this British architect who campaigned for the idea for years. And then he died in one year after his death, the British parliament finally tried out daylight saving time. And that's why we have it today.|||我们讲了威廉·维利的故事。他可以说是夏令时之父。他是这位英国建筑师，多年来一直为这个想法四处奔走呼吁。然后他在死后一年，英国议会终于试行了夏令时。这就是为什么我们今天拥有它。
There's a commemorative sun dial to him in Kent, beautiful, wrap it up with a nice bow type of story. Yes, I remember that part of the story, that's great. So after I put out that story, I got quite a few emails from listeners who were saying, love the story, great job, but wait a second, I thought Benjamin Franklin invented daylight saving time.
There's a commemorative sun dial to him in Kent, beautiful, wrap it up with a nice bow type of story. Yes, I remember that story, that's great. So after I put out that story, I got quite a few emails from listeners who were saying, love the story, great job, but wait a second, I thought Benjamin Franklin invented daylight saving time.|||肯特郡有一座为他建造的纪念日晷，很美，这是一个带有着完美结局的故事。是的，我记得那个故事的一部分，太棒了。在我发布那个故事后，我收到了不少听众的电子邮件，他们说：喜欢这个故事，干得漂亮，但等一下，我以为本杰明·富兰克林发明了夏令时。
Benjamin Franklin, like, yeah, the American founding father, Benjamin Franklin, that guy. Benjamin Franklin, Benjamin Franklin, yeah. Who's responsible for so many things, you know, according to lore? Well, and as soon as I started getting these emails, I was thinking, is he responsible for it? Like, he invented so much other stuff. Like, it seems entirely plausible. So I was thinking, is he responsible for it? Like he invented so much other stuff. Like it seems entirely plausible. So I decided I have to get to the bottom of this. Okay.
Benjamin Franklin, like, yeah, the American founding father, Benjamin Franklin, that guy. Benjamin Franklin, Benjamin Franklin, yeah. Who's responsible for so many things, you know, according to lore? Well, and as soon as I started getting these emails, I was thinking, is he responsible for it? Like, he invented so much other stuff. Like it seems entirely plausible. So I was thinking, is he responsible for it? Like he invented so much other stuff. Like it seems entirely plausible. So I decided I have to get to the bottom of this. Okay.|||本杰明·富兰克林，就像，是的，美国国父，本杰明·富兰克林，那个家伙。本杰明·富兰克林，本杰明·富兰克林，是的。根据传说，他负责了那么多事情？好吧，我一收到这些电子邮件，就在想，是他干的吗？因为他发明了太多别的东西。这听起来完全有可能。所以我在想，是他干的吗？因为他发明了太多别的东西。这听起来完全有可能。所以我决定必须弄个水落石出。好的。
So I did a little investigation. All right. Let's hear it. So I called up this guy. Hello, is this Ranger Thomas Daniels? Oh, yes it is. Should I call you Ranger Daniels? What is the right way to refer to you? You just call me Tom.
So I did a little investigation. All right. Let's hear it. So I called up this guy. Hello, is this Ranger Thomas Daniels? Oh, yes it is. Should I call you Ranger Daniels? What is the right way to refer to you? You just call me Tom.|||所以我做了一点调查。好的。说来听听。所以我给这个人打了个电话。喂，请问是托马斯·丹尼尔斯管理员吗？哦，是的，我是。我该叫你丹尼尔斯管理员吗？正确的称呼方式是什么？你叫我汤姆就行。
So park Ranger Tom Daniels works at the Independence National Park in Philadelphia. It includes lots of American landmarks, including the Liberty Bell and also the Benjamin Franklin Museum. And at the park, he is their resident Benjamin Franklin nut. I would say he's always been a fascinating character for me.
So park Ranger Tom Daniels works at the Independence National Park in Philadelphia. It includes lots of American landmarks, including the Liberty Bell and also the Benjamin Franklin Museum. And at the park, he is their resident Benjamin Franklin nut. I would say he's always been a fascinating character for me.|||公园管理员汤姆·丹尼尔斯在费城的独立国家历史公园工作。这里有许多美国地标，包括自由钟以及本杰明·富兰克林博物馆。在公园里，他是常驻的本杰明·富兰克林狂热爱好者。我想说，他对我来说一直是一个迷人的人物。
And the more you learn about him, the more you're amazed by how much he actually accomplished in one life span. So we talked for a while about Franklin. I explained the whole thing, you know, William Willett, the angry emails, and I finally asked him the question, did Benjamin Franklin invent daylight saving time? So what's fascinating about that is I think this is one of the stories where Benjamin Franklin becomes so famous that he starts getting things attributed to him that are not necessarily attributable to him.
And the more you learn about him, the more you're amazed by how much he actually accomplished in one life span. So we talked for a while about Franklin. I explained the whole thing, you know, William Willett, the angry emails, and I finally asked him the question, did Benjamin Franklin invent daylight saving time? So what's fascinating about that is I think this is one of the stories where Benjamin Franklin becomes so famous that he starts getting things attributed to him that are not necessarily attributable to him.|||你对他的了解越多，就越会对他在短短一生中所取得的成就感到惊叹。所以我们聊了一会儿富兰克林。我解释了整件事，你知道的，威廉·维利、愤怒的电子邮件，我最后问了他一个问题：本杰明·富兰克林发明了夏令时吗？关于这一点，最迷人的是，我认为这是一个这样的故事：本杰明·富兰克林太出名了，以至于人们开始把一些不一定属于他的事情归功于他。
And daylight saving time is one of those. And that's the end of the story. Benjamin Franklin did not invent the... No, there's more. I would expect a little bit more. There's a little bit more. I know this isn't many story, but it's not quite that brief. So there is a funny connection between Benjamin Franklin and daylight saving time.
And daylight saving time is one of those. And that's the end of the story. Benjamin Franklin did not invent the... No, there's more. I would expect a little bit more. There's a little bit more. I know this isn't many story, but it's not quite that brief. So there is a funny connection between Benjamin Franklin and daylight saving time.|||夏令时就是其中之一。故事到此结束。本杰明·富兰克林没有发明……不，还有呢。我本以为会再多一点。还有一点点。我知道这是一个迷你故事，但它没那么简短。所以本杰明·富兰克林和夏令时之间有一个有趣的联系。
It comes from 1776 after the Declaration of Independence was signed and the Continental Congress was getting ready to go to war with Britain for the independence of the United States. And they wanted French military support to fight the war. So they decided we need to send somebody over there who will win over French hearts and minds and who better to send then Benjamin Franklin, the world famous inventor and writer. So they sent Benjamin Franklin over to France as a diplomat. And his charge is to essentially try and secure a formal alliance with the French.
It comes from 1776 after the Declaration of Independence was signed and the Continental Congress was getting ready to go to war with Britain for the independence of the United States. And they wanted French military support to fight the war. So they decided we need to send somebody over there who will win over French hearts and minds and who better to send then Benjamin Franklin, the world famous inventor and writer. So they sent Benjamin Franklin over to France as a diplomat. And his charge is to essentially try and secure a formal alliance with the French.|||它源于1776年《独立宣言》签署之后，大陆会议正准备为美国独立与英国开战。他们需要法国的军事支持来打这场仗。因此，他们决定我们需要派一个人去那里赢得法国人民的心，还有谁比世界闻名的发明家和作家本杰明·富兰克林更适合派遣的呢？于是他们把本杰明·富兰克林作为外交官派往法国。他的任务基本上是试图与法国人确立正式的同盟关系。
There's no guarantees that we were going to be capable of winning independence. So this was going to take a lot of convincing. So Franklin really dived into a, he really ingratiate himself into French society. So what does that mean to ingratiate himself into French design? It basically means he was going to a lot of parties. So every night Ben Franklin was just staying up really late, hanging out with all these important French people. According to some accounts, he was basically living like a college student.
There's no guarantees that we were going to be capable of winning independence. So this was going to take a lot of convincing. So Franklin really dived into a, he really ingratiate himself into French society. So what does that mean to ingratiate himself into French design? It basically means he was going to a lot of parties. So every night Ben Franklin was just staying up really late, hanging out with all these important French people. According to some accounts, he was basically living like a college student.|||无法保证我们一定能够赢得独立。所以这需要大量的说服工作。因此，富兰克林真正投入到……他真正融入了法国社会。那么融入法国设计是什么意思呢？这基本上意味着他参加了大量的聚会。所以每天晚上本·富兰克林都熬得很晚，和所有这些重要的法国人鬼混。根据一些说法，他基本上过着大学生的生活。
And then one day, Benchman Franklin's in Paris, and there's a loud noise outside his window. And he wakes up, and he looks outside, and he sees that the sun is coming up. And it's 6 or noise outside his window. And he wakes up and he looks outside and he sees that the sun is coming up and it's six or seven a.m. and this is a revelation for Benjamin Franklin. And he writes an essay in the Journal of Paris and it's called an economical project.
And then one day, Benchman Franklin's in Paris, and there's a loud noise outside his window. And he wakes up, and he looks outside, and he sees that the sun is coming up. And it's 6 or noise outside his window. And he wakes up and he looks outside and he sees that the sun is coming up and it's six or seven a.m. and this is a revelation for Benjamin Franklin. And he writes an essay in the Journal of Paris and it's called an economical project.|||然后有一天，本杰明·富兰克林在巴黎，他窗外传来一声巨响。他醒来，向外看去，看到太阳正在升起。当时是6点，或者窗外有噪音。他醒来，向外看去，看到太阳正在升起，当时是早上六七点钟，这对于本杰明·富兰克林来说是一个启发。他在《巴黎日报》上写了一篇文章，名叫《一个经济的方案》。
And he basically gently ch castizes the citizens of Paris for not getting up with the sun. The gall of that diplomat to go in there and tell them how to do things. Roman, here, actually Tom read me an excerpt from an economical project. He says, your readers who with me have never seen any sign of sunshine before noon, and seldom regard the astronomical part of the Almanac, will be as much astonished as I was when they hear of his rising so early. And especially when I assure them that he gives light as soon as he rises, I am convinced of this.
And he basically gently ch castizes the citizens of Paris for not getting up with the sun. The gall of that diplomat to go in there and tell them how to do things. Roman, here, actually Tom read me an excerpt from an economical project. He says, your readers who with me have never seen any sign of sunshine before noon, and seldom regard the astronomical part of the Almanac, will be as much astonished as I was when they hear of his rising so early. And especially when I assure them that he gives light as soon as he rises, I am convinced of this.|||他基本上温和地斥责了巴黎市民没有跟随太阳一起起床。那个外交官竟然敢跑到那里去教别人怎么做事，真是好大的胆子。罗曼，这里，实际上汤姆给我读了《一个经济的方案》中的一段。他说，你们的读者和我一样，在中午之前从未见过任何阳光的迹象，也很少关注年历的天文部分，当他们听说太阳升得这么早时，会和我一样惊讶。特别是当我向他们保证它一升起就带来光芒时，我对此深信不疑。
I am certain of my fact one cannot be more certain of any fact I saw it with my own eyes. That is Benjamin Franklin's great revelation is that the sun comes up in the morning. Well, you get a little bit from this tone here of like what he's trying to do. He's overdoing it a little bit in a fun way, actually. Yeah, I mean, Tom called this essay satirical. I think that's right. And it includes these recommendations at the end that are pretty outlandish.
I am certain of my fact one cannot be more certain of any fact I saw it with my own eyes. That is Benjamin Franklin's great revelation is that the sun comes up in the morning. Well, you get a little bit from this tone here of like what he's trying to do. He's overdoing it a little bit in a fun way, actually. Yeah, I mean, Tom called this essay satirical. I think that's right. And it includes these recommendations at the end that are pretty outlandish.|||我对我的事实深信不疑，没有人能对任何事实比这更确信了，我亲眼所见。这就是本杰明·富兰克林的伟大发现——早晨太阳会升起。好吧，从这里的语气中你可以看出他想做什么。实际上，他以一种有趣的方式稍微有些夸张了。是的，我是说，汤姆称这篇文章是讽刺性的。我认为是对的。它在结尾包含了一些非常离奇的建议。
One of the regulations says, every morning, as soon as the sun rises, let all the bells and every church be set ringing. And if that is not sufficient, let canon be bells and every church be set ringing and if that is not sufficient let canon be fired in every street to wake the sluggards affectually and make them open their eyes to see their true interest it
One of the regulations says, every morning, as soon as the sun rises, let all the bells and every church be set ringing. And if that is not sufficient, let canon be bells and every church be set ringing and if that is not sufficient let canon be fired in every street to wake the sluggards affectually and make them open their eyes to see their true interest it|||其中一条规定说，每天早晨，太阳一升起，就让所有的钟声和每一座教堂的钟声都敲响。如果这还不够，就让大炮……钟声和每一座教堂的钟声都敲响，如果这还不够，就在每一条街上鸣炮，以便有效地唤醒懒汉，让他们睁开眼睛看到他们真正的利益，它
it's a fair and it can't be pretty extreme but i i i have to kind of i kind of did it i mean rubin what else is going to awaken the sluggards right you have to affectually awaken the sluggards, right? You have to effectively awaken those sluggards. Okay. So in conclusion, Benjamin Franklin did not event daylight saving time. He did write this funny essay about everyone in Paris waking up to the sounds of cannons being fired, which I guess is why people make that mistake because it's also about waking up earlier with the sun. But there's something bigger going on here, which is that lots of inventions get attributed
it's a fair and it can't be pretty extreme but i i i have to kind of i kind of did it i mean rubin what else is going to awaken the sluggards right you have to affectually awaken the sluggards, right? You have to effectively awaken those sluggards. Okay. So in conclusion, Benjamin Franklin did not event daylight saving time. He did write this funny essay about everyone in Paris waking up to the sounds of cannons being fired, which I guess is why people make that mistake because it's also about waking up earlier with the sun. But there's something bigger going on here, which is that lots of inventions get attributed|||这很公平，而且可能相当极端，但我不得不……我有点……我是说，鲁本，还有什么能唤醒懒汉呢，对吧？你必须有效地唤醒那些懒汉，对吧？你必须有效地唤醒那些懒汉。好的。总之，本杰明·富兰克林没有发明夏令时。他确实写了这篇有趣的短文，讲述巴黎的所有人都在炮声中醒来，我猜这就是为什么人们会犯这个错误，因为它也关乎伴随太阳更早地醒来。但这里发生了一件更重大的事，那就是许多发明被归功于
to Benjamin Franklin that he is not responsible for. And Tom told me this actually happens at his job sometimes. I think the most famous one is people think that he invented, they think he invented the light bulb, which of course was Thomas Edison. I think the confusion comments from Franklin's experiments were the electricity. Some other common ones I found on the internet,
to Benjamin Franklin that he is not responsible for. And Tom told me this actually happens at his job sometimes. I think the most famous one is people think that he invented, they think he invented the light bulb, which of course was Thomas Edison. I think the confusion comments from Franklin's experiments were the electricity. Some other common ones I found on the internet,|||本杰明·富兰克林，而他其实并未参与。汤姆告诉我，这在他的工作中实际上有时会发生。我认为最著名的一个是人们以为他发明了，他们以为他发明了电灯泡，当然那是托马斯·爱迪生。我认为混淆之处来自于富兰克林关于电力的实验。我在网上发现的其他一些常见例子，
there are people who believe Benjamin Franklin invented the street light. He did not invent the street light. He was involved in improving a certain design of street light. There is actually a page on the Franklin Institute website dedicated to quotes that are falsely attributed to Ben Franklin. So would you like to hear it example? I'd love to. Yeah. OK. Any fool can criticize, condemn, and complain.
there are people who believe Benjamin Franklin invented the street light. He did not invent the street light. He was involved in improving a certain design of street light. There is actually a page on the Franklin Institute website dedicated to quotes that are falsely attributed to Ben Franklin. So would you like to hear it example? I'd love to. Yeah. OK. Any fool can criticize, condemn, and complain.|||有些人认为本杰明·富兰克林发明了路灯。他并没有发明路灯。他参与改进了某种路灯设计。富兰克林研究所的网站上实际上有一页专门收录了被错误归功于本·富兰克林的引言。你想听个例子吗？我很乐意。好的。任何傻瓜都可以批评、谴责和抱怨。
And most fools do. Oh, OK. That that sounds very Franklin-y. Or yeah, it's kind of Mark Twainy as well, you know what I mean? But yeah. It's a little more modern than that. That was actually said by Dale Carnegie, the guy who wrote,
And most fools do. Oh, OK. That that sounds very Franklin-y. Or yeah, it's kind of Mark Twainy as well, you know what I mean? But yeah. It's a little more modern than that. That was actually said by Dale Carnegie, the guy who wrote,|||大多数傻瓜也确实这么做。哦，好吧。听起来真像富兰克林说的话。或者，是的，也有点像马克·吐温的风格，你知道我的意思吗？但是，是的。它比那个要现代一些。这话实际上是戴尔·卡耐基说的，也就是写了
How to Infrains and Influence People. So someone who's pretty different. Well, this is so fascinating. Well, so Benjamin Franklin did a lot of amazing things and we were not diminished from Benjamin Franklin, but he did not invent daylight saving time. He did not invent daylight saving time, not to diminish his other accomplishments.
How to Infrains and Influence People. So someone who's pretty different. Well, this is so fascinating. Well, so Benjamin Franklin did a lot of amazing things and we were not diminished from Benjamin Franklin, but he did not invent daylight saving time. He did not invent daylight saving time, not to diminish his other accomplishments.|||《人性的弱点》的那个人。所以是一个相当不同的人。这太迷人了。好吧，本杰明·富兰克林做了许多了不起的事情，我们并没有因此贬低本杰明·富兰克林，但他没有发明夏令时。他没有发明夏令时，这并不贬低他的其他成就。
Please be careful when you're reading those articles online that say the 10 amazing things created by Ben Franklin. Please approach those with suspicion. That's a good warning. Thanks so much, Chris. Thanks, Roman. Thanks. Coming up, we get to the bottom of the fire poll after this.
Please be careful when you're reading those articles online that say the 10 amazing things created by Ben Franklin. Please approach those with suspicion. That's a good warning. Thanks so much, Chris. Thanks, Roman. Thanks. Coming up, we get to the bottom of the fire poll after this.|||当你阅读网上那些声称“本·富兰克林创造的10个惊人事物”的文章时，请小心。请带着怀疑的态度去看待它们。这是一个很好的警告。非常感谢，克里斯。谢谢，罗曼。谢谢。接下来，广告之后我们将探究消防滑竿的真相。
So I'm here with producer Lausanne Donne. Hey, Lausanne. Hey, Roman. So what do you have for us? Well, I wanted to talk with you about fire polls. Oh, excellent. I was just thinking about fire poles and that I didn't know what they were all about. But you're talking about the shiny brass poles that firefighters lie down to get from the second floor to the first floor. Exactly.
So I'm here with producer Lausanne Donne. Hey, Lausanne. Hey, Roman. So what do you have for us? Well, I wanted to talk with you about fire polls. Oh, excellent. I was just thinking about fire poles and that I didn't know what they were all about. But you're talking about the shiny brass poles that firefighters lie down to get from the second floor to the first floor. Exactly.|||我现在和制片人洛桑·唐恩在一起。嘿，洛桑。嘿，罗曼。你给我们带了什么？嗯，我想跟你聊聊消防滑竿。哦，太棒了。我刚才还在想消防滑竿，我不知道它们是怎么回事。但你说的是消防员用来从二楼滑到一楼的那根闪亮的黄铜滑竿吧。正是。
And sometimes from the third floor to the first floor. So the fire pole as an object is pretty symbolic of the firefighting profession, right? But the actual use of the poll has kind of become a thing of the past. If you learned about firefighters as a kid, maybe from your parents or teachers or even a storybook, you were probably told about the poll because at one time it was in nearly every fire station. And he guesses why? Well, my first guess is the obvious one, which is it gets you from one
And sometimes from the third floor to the first floor. So the fire pole as an object is pretty symbolic of the firefighting profession, right? But the actual use of the poll has kind of become a thing of the past. If you learned about firefighters as a kid, maybe from your parents or teachers or even a storybook, you were probably told about the poll because at one time it was in nearly every fire station. And he guesses why? Well, my first guess is the obvious one, which is it gets you from one|||有时是从三楼到一楼。所以消防滑竿作为一种物体，可以说是消防职业的象征，对吧？但滑竿的实际使用已经成为过去式了。如果你小时候了解过消防员，也许是从父母、老师甚至故事书里，你可能听说过滑竿，因为一度几乎每个消防局里都有它。有人猜猜为什么吗？好吧，我的第一个猜测是显而易见的，那就是它可以让你从一个
four to the other very, very fast. Right. Fast was the way to go. Putting out a fire fast meant getting to the fire fast. And for years, fire poles have helped firefighters do that. But the origin story of the pole is actually pretty interesting. Okay, we'll lay it on me. I called up retired Chicago Battalion Chief DeCalb Walcott Jr. My name is DeCalb Walcott Jr. I moved to the ranks from fireman, engineer, lieutenant captain, and served four years as a battalion chief. So Chief Walcott is fine. Chief Walcott is now a firefighter historian. He's been archiving Black Firefighter History in Chicago where our fire poll origin story takes place. But Roman, before we get to the polls,
four to the other very, very fast. Right. Fast was the way to go. Putting out a fire fast meant getting to the fire fast. And for years, fire poles have helped firefighters do that. But the origin story of the poll is actually pretty interesting. Okay, we'll lay it on me. I called up retired Chicago Battalion Chief DeCalb Walcott Jr. My name is DeCalb Walcott Jr. I moved to the ranks from fireman, engineer, lieutenant captain, and served four years as a battalion chief. So Chief Walcott is fine. Chief Walcott is now a firefighter historian. He's been archiving Black Firefighter History in Chicago where our fire poll origin story takes place. But Roman, before we get to the polls,|||楼层非常非常快地到达另一个楼层。没错。快就是王道。快速灭火意味着快速到达火灾现场。多年来，消防滑竿一直帮助消防员做到这一点。但滑竿的起源故事其实相当有趣。好吧，快告诉我吧。我打电话给芝加哥退休营长小德卡尔布·沃尔科特。我的名字叫小德卡尔布·沃尔科特。我从消防员、工程师、中尉晋升到上尉，并担任了四年营长。所以叫沃尔科特长官就行。沃尔科特长官现在是一名消防历史学家。他一直在芝加哥归档黑人消防员的历史，我们的消防滑竿起源故事就发生在那里。但罗曼，在我们谈到滑竿之前，
let's talk about the firefighters. Okay. The first firefighters were the Bucket Brigade. This was the 1600s before engines and hoses. They would have a long line of they would have a long line of men, women, children, slaves, freedmen, whoever could hold a bucket, probably. And they passed the buckets on until they got to the seat of the fire or the person that was first in line. That was dumped in the water. The bucket brigade was basically a long human chain. Over time, they improved the system of firefighting
let's talk about the firefighters. Okay. The first firefighters were the Bucket Brigade. This was the 1600s before engines and hoses. They would have a long line of they would have a long line of men, women, children, slaves, freedmen, whoever could hold a bucket, probably. And they passed the buckets on until they got to the seat of the fire or the person that was first in line. That was dumped in the water. The bucket brigade was basically a long human chain. Over time, they improved the system of firefighting|||先来谈谈消防员。好的。最早的消防员是水桶队。这是17世纪，在出现消防车和水带之前。他们会排成长队——他们会有由男人、女人、儿童、奴隶、自由民组成的很长的队伍，大概任何能拿得动水桶的人都可以。他们传递水桶，直到水桶传到火源处或排在队伍最前面的人那里。水被倒在火上。水桶队基本上就是一条漫长的人链。随着时间的推移，他们改进了消防系统，
with the goal of putting fires out as fast as possible. By the 1800s, there were engines being pulled by horses. But one thing didn't change throughout this whole time period. Each group of firefighters, which were called fire companies, were in furious competition to fight the same fire. Huh, so why were they competing?
with the goal of putting fires out as fast as possible. By the 1800s, there were engines being pulled by horses. But one thing didn't change throughout this whole time period. Each group of firefighters, which were called fire companies, were in furious competition to fight the same fire. Huh, so why were they competing?|||目标是以最快速度扑灭火灾。到了19世纪，出现了由马匹拉动的消防车。但在整个这一时期，有一件事没有改变。每组消防员（被称为消防连队）都在激烈竞争，争着去扑灭同一场火灾。嗯，那他们为什么要竞争呢？
Originally, volunteer companies were basically at the whim of the insurance carrier. Whoever got to the fire first put water on the fire first, were the ones who were paid. And no one else was paid, even if they got there a little bit later. No. Essentially insurance companies would pay only one fire company. The one that made it to the scene,
Originally, volunteer companies were basically at the whim of the insurance carrier. Whoever got to the fire first put water on the fire first, were the ones who were paid. And no one else was paid, even if they got there a little bit later. No. Essentially insurance companies would pay only one fire company. The one that made it to the scene,|||最初，志愿消防连队基本上听命于保险公司。谁先赶到火灾现场并率先向火灾喷水，谁就能拿到报酬。其他人即使稍微晚到一会儿也拿不到报酬。没有。基本上保险公司只付钱给一家消防连队。也就是赶到现场的那家，
hooked up to the hydrant and put out the fire first. And with so much competition, things got messy. This seems like a really bad system, bad setup. So can you tell me more about how it got more messy? Yeah, I mean, well, so first of all, most firefighters weren't getting paid much at all. Insurance companies would offer incentives to particular fire stations over others, and so those fire stations sometimes did what they could to slow down their rivals.
hooked up to the hydrant and put out the fire first. And with so much competition, things got messy. This seems like a really bad system, bad setup. So can you tell me more about how it got more messy? Yeah, I mean, well, so first of all, most firefighters weren't getting paid much at all. Insurance companies would offer incentives to particular fire stations over others, and so those fire stations sometimes did what they could to slow down their rivals.|||连接到消防栓并率先将火扑灭的那家。由于竞争如此激烈，事情变得一团糟。这看起来真的是个很糟糕的系统，糟糕的设置。你能多讲讲它是怎么变得更糟的吗？是的，我的意思是，首先，大多数消防员根本拿不到多少报酬。保险公司会向特定的消防局提供优于其他消防局的奖励，因此这些消防局有时会不择手段地拖慢竞争对手的速度。
Decalb told me there was also a huge culture of drinking among volunteer firefighters. Many firehouses were even outfitted with their own bars. And in Chicago, Decalb said that taverns would sometimes give alcohol out to firefighters at the scene of a fire to help them get their bravery up. And sometimes that alcohol helped facilitate full-on brawls on the street. And they were getting to fights not only with the public but also with the other fire companies they were competing against. There were a lot of complaints by the public also because here you have a fire company fighting in the street when they
Decalb told me there was also a huge culture of drinking among volunteer firefighters. Many firehouses were even outfitted with their own bars. And in Chicago, Decalb said that taverns would sometimes give alcohol out to firefighters at the scene of a fire to help them get their bravery up. And sometimes that alcohol helped facilitate full-on brawls on the street. And they were getting to fights not only with the public but also with the other fire companies they were competing against. There were a lot of complaints by the public also because here you have a fire company fighting in the street when they|||德卡尔布告诉我，志愿消防员中也存在着浓厚的酗酒文化。许多消防局甚至配备了自己的酒吧。在芝加哥，德卡尔布说小酒馆有时会在火灾现场向消防员提供酒精，以帮助他们鼓起勇气。有时这些酒精会在街头引发全面的斗殴。他们不仅与公众打架，还与他们竞争的其他消防连队打架。公众也有很多抱怨，因为这里有一个消防连队在街头打架，而他们本该
should be putting water on fire. So there'd be like fire-consuming and building and firefighters from different stations would be having like a brawl in the street right in front of it. Yes, exactly. Terrifying image, okay. And it's in this competitive atmosphere that a new fire station, engine company 21, is formed. Engine 21 was an all black fire company. And actually, engine 21 was the first paid black fire company in the country. Actually, Engine 21 was the first paid black fire company in the country. They had approximately eight black members. Many of those members were ex-civil war veterans and also slaves.
should be putting water on fire. So there'd be like fire-consuming and building and firefighters from different stations would be having like a brawl in the street right in front of it. Yes, exactly. Terrifying image, okay. And it's in this competitive atmosphere that a new fire station, engine company 21, is formed. Engine 21 was an all black fire company. And actually, engine 21 was the first paid black fire company in the country. Actually, Engine 21 was the first paid black fire company in the country. They had approximately eight black members. Many of those members were ex-civil war veterans and also slaves.|||去向大火喷水。所以会发生这样的情况：房屋在大火中燃烧，而来自不同消防局的消防员却在它面前的街道上大打出手。是的，完全正确。可怕的画面，好吧。正是在这种竞争激烈的氛围中，一个新的消防局——21号机车消防连队成立了。21号是全黑人消防连队。事实上，21号是全国第一家有报酬的黑人消防连队。事实上，21号是全国第一家有报酬的黑人消防连队。他们大约有八名黑人成员。其中许多成员是前南北战争退伍军人以及奴隶。
So it was 1872, and for the very first time, the mayor of Chicago, Joseph Medil, allowed black people to join the Chicago Fire Department. As you can imagine, members of the newly formed engine 21 Firehouse felt a particular need to prove themselves. An engine 21 is credited with coming up with the fire pole. Oh, this is so fascinating. Okay, so how did that happen? Well, Roman, it has to do with horses and staircases and a whole lot of hay.
So it was 1872, and for the very first time, the mayor of Chicago, Joseph Medil, allowed black people to join the Chicago Fire Department. As you can imagine, members of the newly formed engine 21 Firehouse felt a particular need to prove themselves. And engine 21 is credited with coming up with the fire pole. Oh, this is so fascinating. Okay, so how did that happen? Well, Roman, it has to do with horses and staircases and a whole lot of hay.|||那是1872年，芝加哥市长约瑟夫·梅迪尔首次允许黑人加入芝加哥消防局。你可以想象，新成立的21号消防局的成员们感到特别需要证明自己。而21号消防局被公认为发明了消防滑竿。哦，这太迷人了。好吧，那是怎么发生的呢？嗯，罗曼，这与马匹、楼梯和大量的干草有关。
Okay, I have no idea where this is going because I'm pretty sure horses can't use fire ball. But let's let's I can't wait to learn more. Roman, have you ever been inside a fire station? Yeah, I've been to them. Yeah, sure. There's lots of different ones. There's a cool round one and sort of the Albany, a Berkeley junction that I've been
Okay, I have no idea where this is going because I'm pretty sure horses can't use fire ball. But let's let's I can't wait to learn more. Roman, have you ever been inside a fire station? Yeah, I've been to them. Yeah, sure. There's lots of different ones. There's a cool round one and sort of the Albany, a Berkeley junction that I've been|||好吧，我完全不知道这会通向何方，因为我很确定马不能用消防滑竿。但让我们……我迫不及待地想了解更多。罗曼，你进过消防局吗？去过，我去过。是的，当然。有很多不同的消防局。有一个很酷的圆形消防局，还有我在奥尔尼、伯克利交界处去过的那种
inside. Yeah. So the traditional structure of most firehouses of the 1800s, like Engine 21, were built three stories high. The horses were stable on the first floor, the human sleeping and eating quarters on the second, hay on the third, and a set of stairs connecting them. It worked pretty well, except that the horses would often follow the smell of human food and try to climb up the stairs. And the horses can make it up a set of stairs just fine, but when it comes to going down the stairs, they'd often get stuck.
inside. Yeah. So the traditional structure of most firehouses of the 1800s, like Engine 21, were built three stories high. The horses were stable on the first floor, the human sleeping and eating quarters on the second, hay on the third, and a set of stairs connecting them. It worked pretty well, except that the horses would often follow the smell of human food and try to climb up the stairs. And the horses can make it up a set of stairs just fine, but when it comes to going down the stairs, they'd often get stuck.|||内部。是的。因此，19世纪大多数消防局的传统结构，比如21号，都是建三层楼高。一楼是马厩，二楼是人类的卧室和餐厅，三楼是干草，还有一组楼梯连接它们。这运转得挺好，除了马匹经常会顺着人类食物的气味试图爬上楼梯。马匹上楼梯倒没什么问题，但如果要下楼梯，它们经常会被卡住。
Okay, that sounds hairline. Now, Roman, we've never had to remove a spookt horse from the stairway at work, have we? No, no, definitely not. They think it's... But if we did, we'd quickly find a way to make sure that doesn't happen again. That's what then happens once. So to solve for this problem, most fire companies
Okay, that sounds hairline. Now, Roman, we're never had to remove a spookt horse from the stairway at work, have we? No, no, definitely not. They think it's... But if we did, we'd quickly find a way to make sure that doesn't happen again. That's what then happens once. So to solve for this problem, most fire companies|||好吧，听起来挺惊险的。罗曼，我们在工作中可从没清理过楼梯上受惊的马吧？没有，没有，绝对没有。他们觉得……但如果我们真的遇到了，我们会迅速找到方法确保这种事不再发生。事情就是这样发生的。为了解决这个问题，大多数消防连队
blocked off the old stairs, and they put in one very tight spiral staircase, which was fully horse proof. But this caused a new problem. It took a lot longer for a team of firefighters to get down a tight spiral staircase. And if engine 21's firefighters were too slow out the door, they wouldn't be the first to the fire. And if it happened too often, they couldn't save lives, couldn't make a living, and their
blocked off the old stairs, and they put in one very tight spiral staircase, which was fully horse proof. But this caused a new problem. It took a lot longer for a team of firefighters to get down a tight spiral staircase. And if engine 21's firefighters were too slow out the door, they wouldn't be the first to the fire. And if it happened too often, they couldn't save lives, couldn't make a living, and their|||封锁了旧楼梯，并安装了一个非常紧凑的螺旋楼梯，完全防马。但这引发了一个新问题。消防员团队顺着狭窄的螺旋楼梯下来需要花费长得多的时间。如果21号消防员出门太慢，他们就无法第一个到达火灾现场。如果这种情况发生得太频繁，他们就无法拯救生命，无法谋生，他们的
reputation might suffer too to the point where maybe they'd stop getting calls altogether. Mm-hmm. Engine 21's total, brought on competition. In order for engine 21 to survive during that time period, they had to do everything right. They had to be correct. Couldn't get in all the occasions on the street when people would call them out of the name.
声誉也可能会受损，甚至可能再也接不到任何出警电话了。嗯。21号消防队面临的全面竞争。为了在那个时期生存下来，21号消防队必须把每件事都做好。他们必须做到绝对正确。不能理会街上那些对他们出言不逊的人。
I've read many instances where they went in the bars or taverns and were not served, even in uniform. And that's kind of how it went for a couple years. And then one night in 1878, engine 21 firefighter George Reed was in the hay loft on the third floor when the alarm went off. He acted on instinct. And instead of running down two flights of spiral stairs
我读过很多这样的例子：他们走进酒吧或小酒馆时被拒绝接待，哪怕他们还穿着制服。这种情况持续了好几年。然后，在1878年的一个晚上，21号消防队的消防员乔治·里德（George Reed）正在三楼的干草阁里，这时警报响了。他凭直觉行动。他没有跑下两段旋转楼梯
to catch up to the group, he just slid down a pole from the third floor all the way down to the first. Where did the pole come from? So the pole was a wooden binding pole that was used for securing hay to the wagon during transport. When that pole was in use, it was stored vertically from the loading area all the way up to the hay loft. So anyway, George was able to get saddled in and ready to go way before anyone else who took the winding staircase from the second floor. And people were like, where did you come from?
去追赶大部队，而是直接从三楼顺着一根杆子一直滑到了一楼。这根杆子是从哪来的？这根杆子其实是一根木质捆绑杆，在运输过程中用来把干草固定在马车上。当这根杆子不用时，它会从装载区一直垂直存放到干草阁。不管怎样，乔治设法绑好装备并准备好出发，比任何其他人都要快，那些人则是走了二楼的旋转楼梯。人们当时都在想：你是从哪儿冒出来的？
How'd you get here so fast? And then later, engine 21's captain, captain Kenyon was like, let's install a permanent hole in the floor, run a three inch round wooden pole through the hole, and why don't we just slide that instead of taking the stairs? So they did. So they get down three stories really, really fast.
你怎么来得这么快？后来，21号消防队的队长肯扬队长（Captain Kenyon）说：我们在地板上安个固定的洞吧，在洞里穿一根三英寸粗的圆木杆，我们为什么不直接滑这个下去，而不是走楼梯呢？于是他们照做了。所以他们以极快、极快的速度下到了三层楼。
Does actually help them get to the virus first? Well, I should say that Decalb told me that at first, engine 21 was the butt of many jokes because of the pole. They were laughed at. You know, it was a joke to everybody else, but it was stopped being a joke when they found out that engine 21 was putting out their fires getting in first. And the city, as a matter of fact, and a report for April of 1878 stated
这真的能帮他们最先赶到火灾现场吗？嗯，我应该说，德卡尔布（Decalb）告诉我，起初，21号消防队因为这根杆子成了许多笑话的笑柄。他们被群嘲了。你知道的，对其他人来说这只是个笑话，但当他们发现21号消防队总是能扑灭火灾、最先赶到现场时，这就不再是个笑话了。事实上，在1878年4月份的一份城市报告中指出
that sliding poles increase members response time. And as a result, sliding poles were being installed throughout Chicago, throughout all the firehouses in Chicago. Hmm. I mean, I can imagine that sliding down a pole, instead of going down a tight spiral staircase, would shave off a few seconds. But it doesn't sound like a lot of time, but maybe, you know, that's enough of an edge, right? I mean, maybe that's the difference between life and death
使用滑杆缩短了队员们的出警反应时间。因此，滑杆开始在芝加哥全市推广，安装在芝加哥所有的消防局里。嗯。我可以想象，顺着杆子滑下来，而不是走狭窄的旋转楼梯，可以节省几秒钟的时间。听起来时间好像不多，但也许，你知道的，这就足够形成优势了，对吧？我的意思是，这或许就是生死之隔
and some situations that could mean everything. Mm-hmm. Yeah. And Engine 21 didn't just install a poll. They turned that poll into their skill, one that set them apart from all other fire companies, because it's not as easy as it looks to slide efficiently down. A thin wooden pole, multiple flights of stairs, but they became very good at their craft. They would drill in the daytime. They had their time frame was 12 to 14 seconds getting out of the door. That's astounding. We can't do that today.
在某些情况下，这意味着一切。嗯。是的。而且21号消防队不仅安装了一根杆子。他们把这根杆子变成了一项绝技，让他们在所有其他消防中队中脱颖而出，因为要高效地顺着一根细木杆滑过好几层楼梯并不像看起来那么容易，但他们对这项技能变得非常熟练。他们会在白天进行训练，他们的目标时间是12到14秒内冲出门外。太惊人了。我们现在可做不到这一点。
They would drill regularly doing that though. They would slide the pole hook the horses up and out the door. They went. Wow. In 12 to 14 seconds. Yeah. The fire pole, it revolutionized the way firefighters responded to emergencies. And eventually they were installed around the world.
不过他们确实会定期进行这种训练。他们会滑杆、给马套上挽具，然后冲出门去。他们出发了。哇。在12到14秒内。是的。消防滑杆彻底改变了消防员应对紧急情况的方式。最终它们被安装到了世界各地。
Like you said, it saved lives. But the pole also created a new kind of problem for firefighters, a new kind of life or death problem. Because in leaping onto the pole and accelerating, firefighters were sometimes injuring themselves before they even got to the scene. I've heard stories of intoxicated firemen going to reach the slide to pole, missed the pole,
正如你所说，它拯救了生命。但滑杆也为消防员带来了一种新问题，一种生死攸关的新问题。因为在扑向滑杆并加速下落时，消防员有时甚至还没到达现场就先把自己弄伤了。我听说过一些喝醉酒的消防员摇摇晃晃地准备去抓滑杆，结果抓了个空，
and his head was the first thing that hit the concrete. Spraying ankles, concussions, falls, some inebriated or sleepwalking firefighters have simply wandered over the hole and fallen into it, accidentally falling 20 or 30 feet. And at their most dangerous, the poles have led to deaths. Today, fire poles have been phased out of use
头部先着地，撞在了水泥地上。脚踝扭伤、脑震荡、跌落，一些醉酒或梦游的消防员无意中走到洞口并掉了进去，不小心坠落了20或30英尺。而在最危险的情况下，这些滑杆甚至导致了死亡。如今，消防滑杆已经逐步被淘汰出局
in a lot of cities. Hmm, so if firefighters aren't using fire poles, are they back to using spiral staircases? Well, without horses, there's no need for horse-proof staircases. Oh, right. That makes sense. Yeah, OK.
在许多城市。嗯，如果消防员不再使用消防滑杆，他们是改回使用旋转楼梯了吗？好吧，既然不用马了，也就不需要防马的旋转楼梯了。哦，对了。这倒说得通。对，好吧。
In multi-story fire houses, some have considered installing slides and other straight staircases, although both options are slower than what engine 21's response time was with the pole. And most newer fire stations now operate from a single story of space permits, both options are slower than what engine 21's response time was with the poll. And most newer fire stations now operate from a single story of space permits, so they're on the ground floor already. But all this doesn't mean that you won't see a fire poll in your local firehouse anymore.
在多层消防局里，一些人曾考虑安装滑梯和其他直楼梯，尽管这两种选项的速度都比不上21号消防队当年使用滑杆时的出警反应时间。而且现在大多数较新的消防局如果空间允许的话，都是单层运营的，所以他们本来就在底楼。但这一切并不意味着你在当地的消防局里再也见不到消防滑杆了。
Just that over time, it's really just become a symbol. Yeah, I mean, considering that it went through a phase of non-existing, it existed for a while, and now it's being phased out, it really has stuck in the popular imagination. Like, if you'd asked anyone, but they'd find it in a firehouse, they would talk about an engine, maybe a Dalmatian, and then there would be like a pole.
只是随着时间的推移，它真的变成了一个象征。是的，考虑到它经历过不复存在的阶段，存在了一段时间，而现在又正被逐步淘汰，它确实深深扎根于大众的想象中。比如，如果你问任何人他们会在消防局里找到什么，他们可能会谈到一辆消防车，也许还有一只大麦町犬，然后就会是一根滑杆。
Like, my kids could tell you about a fire pole, even though they probably weren't inactive use during their lifetimes. Right. Yeah, I even read an article with an architect who specializes in firehouse design. And he said that in his latest designs, fire poles were specifically requested
比如，我的孩子们能跟你讲讲消防滑杆，尽管在他们有生之年这东西可能已经不再投入实际使用了。对。是的，我甚至读过一篇采访一位专注于消防局设计的建筑师的文章。他说，在他的最新设计中，城市管理者们专门要求安装消防滑杆
by city administrators because of what they represented, even though the firefighters these days wouldn't necessarily use them. These days, it's just simultaneously an emblem of innovation and of tradition. Well, it's so cool. I'm so glad I know more about Firefall site. This is great, Lasha. Thanks so much. Thank you. 99% of visible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, Lasha Madonna and Chris Barube,
因为它们所代表的意义，尽管如今的消防员们未必会真的使用它们。如今，它同时成为了创新与传统的象征。嗯，太酷了。很高兴能对消防滑杆有更多了解。太棒了，拉莎（Lasha）。非常感谢。谢谢。本周的《99%无形》由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、拉莎·麦唐娜（Lasha Madonna）和克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）制作，
mixed in tech production by Amida Kanatra, music by our director of Sound, Swan Rihau. To Linhual, as executive producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director, the rest of the team is Christopher Johnson, Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Jacob Moltenado Medina for production help on the mini stories this year. We are part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown Oakland California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook you can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99 PI org on Instagram and read it too. You can find links
混音和技术制作由阿米达·卡纳特拉（Amida Kanatra）负责，音乐由我们的声音总监斯旺·里豪（Swan Rihau）创作。图琳·格瓦尔（To Linhual）担任执行制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead）担任数字总监，团队其他成员包括克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、维维安·勒（Vivian Le）、约瑟夫·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、索菲娅·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。特别感谢雅各布·莫尔特纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Moltenado Medina）对今年迷你故事制作提供的帮助。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部现在设在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区潘多拉大楼往北六个街区的地方。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论，你可以在推特上@Roman Mars，或者在Instagram和Reddit上@99 PI org。你还可以找到链接
to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 9-9-PI, including 13 more volumes of many stories if you like that sort of thing at 99PI.org You've been listening to A Stitcher Podcast from SiriusXM. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
去了解我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目，以及9-9-PI的每一期往期节目，包括如果你喜欢这类内容的话还有另外13卷迷你故事，尽在99PI.org。你收听的是来自SiriusXM的Stitcher播客。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。